[Music]
despite what many people are probably
feeling was a divisive campaign
americans are believe it or not hopeful
as they come together to vote we spoke
with voters of all backgrounds from the
east coast to the west
and north to south and they told us
about their hopes for
after election day and their dreams for
our country's future
[Music]
my hopes are that the country will calm
down
and that we don't have to think about
politics on a daily basis
recently we've had a big divide in the
country
and i really just want everyone to come
together again we can all come together
and be one country
one group of americans
decency fairness humanity and all that
is right in the world
we have to vote for the america that we
dream of
normalcy hope the country just gets back
to normalcy
vote like we never did before every
single vote matters
[Music]
thank you everybody have a good time get
out and vote
i feel like 2020 has been very
challenging and difficult for
many of us but on election day we all
get to come together and collectively
show our power
i want to see a better change in the
world for people that look like
me i think we're re-defining what it
means to be an american
and i think it's really important that
go out and vote and make sure that your
voice is counted
i have never missed a presidential
voting
since i've been on the planet
me being an immigrant believe me
everybody should vote
i was talking with a friend of mine and
they were saying that americans
they vote and then they go for ice cream
like it's such an american thing
you know and i'm this is my first time
voting so i was like so excited i was
like okay are we getting ice cream now
we all have to vote our conscience we
have to elevate our human consciousness
and vote for the type of country we want
to see the type of world we want
and so that way it it affects the whole
world
my biggest wish for the election
is that we're able to heal the divisions
between the political parties
and accomplish something positive
it's a privilege to exercise our right
to vote i think that ultimately it's the
people who speak
and so as my shirt says you know my
voice is my vote
this is what we should be doing you know
we should be coming out and voting it's
it's our right and i think as citizens
it's
our responsibility i'm hoping that the
american people are just going to voice
their
voices and just create this country into
the most awesome place on earth
i got the bell and i remember like
shaking as i was writing just like
because
wow like my vote counts
yes young lady your vote does count
that's that to me is a much needed
reminder about
who we are as a country it's not a
surprising bit of power when you put
that yeah
i actually did i felt power and i felt a
lot of pride too
yeah it said your vote has been been
counted i have goosebumps right now
hearing from those voters and i hope if
you haven't voted go out today you still
have time to do it it really matters and
i do share
the sentiment that one young woman
shared that the country will calm down
after all this yes yes
taylor swift has a song that says you
need to calm down let's all take that
advice